let's have some subspace of RN called V
let me draw it like this so that is RN
that is RN at some subspace of it that
will call V right here so that is my
subspace V we know that the orthogonal
complement of V the orthogonal
complement of V is equal to the the set
of all of the members of RN all of the
members of RN so X is a member of RN
such that X dot V is equal to 0 for
every for every V that is a member of
our subspace so our orthogonal
complement of our subspaces only all of
the vectors that are orthogonal to all
of these vectors and we've seen before
that they only overlap there's only one
vector that's a member of both and
that's the zero vector let's it's right
there let's take the orthogonal
complement let's say it's this set right
here in pink so that's the orthogonal
complement fair enough now what if we
were to think about the orthogonal
complement of the orthogonal complement
so we want the orthogonal complement so
that's the orthogonal complement that's
the whole thing in pink but we want the
orthogonal complement of that so this is
going to be all of the X's let's just
write it like this all of the X's that
are members of RN such that such that X
dot let me just say X dot W is equal to
0
for every W that is a member of the
orthogonal complement of V that's what
that thing is saying so it's all of the
vectors in RN that are orthogonal to
everything here now we can think
obviously all of the things in V are
going to be a member of that because
these guys are orthogonal to everything
in these guys but maybe there's maybe
this is just a subset or of the
orthogonal complement of the orthogonal
complement so maybe this thing in blue
right here looks like this maybe it's a
slightly larger set than V maybe
there are some things these things that
I'm shading in blue maybe there are some
vectors that are orthogonal to the
orthogonal complement of V but that are
outside of V we don't know that yet we
don't know yet we don't know whether
those whether this area right here
exists or maybe the orthogonal
complement of the orthogonal complement
maybe that takes us back to V maybe it's
like the transpose or an inverse
function where it just goes back to our
original subspace so let's see if we can
think about that a little bit better so
let's say let's say that I have some
member of the orthogonal complement of
the orthogonal complement so let's say I
have some vector X that is a member of
the orthogonal complement of the
orthogonal complement now we saw in the
last video that any vector in RN can be
represented by a sum of some vector in a
subspace and the subspaces complement so
if I have so we know that X can be
represented we can say that X can be
represented as a sum of two vectors
wanted that's in V and one that's in the
orthogonal complement of V so one let's
call that the vector that's in V and
let's call W the vector that's in the
orthogonal complement of V let me write
it like this where where V is a member
of the subspace V and the vector W is a
member of the orthogonal complement of V
right so this is some member you know it
could be it could be some guy out here
it could be some guy over here he's a
member of the orthogonal complement of
the orthogonal complement which is this
whole area here which V is a subset up
but we're not sure whether V equals that
thing but we say look it any anything
that's in are in the Christoffel
complement of the orthogonal complement
is going to be a member of RN and
anything in RN can be represented as the
sum of a vector in V and a vector in the
orthogonal complement of V so that's all
I wrote right there now what happens if
I dot if I take the dot product of X
with W what is this going to be equal to
well this is the orthogonal complement
of the orthogonal complement so if you
take the dot product of any vector in
this with any vector in the orthogonal
complement which this vector is right
it's a member of the orthogonal
complement you're going to get zero by
definition these are all of the vectors
this vector is definitely orthogonal to
anything in just V perp write anything
in V perp perp is orthogonal to anything
in V perp so this thing is going to be
equal to zero but what's another way of
writing XW we could write it like this
this is the same thing as V plus W dot W
which is the same thing as V dot W plus
W dot W now what is V dot W V is a
member of our original subspace is an
original subspace and if you take the
dot product of anything with our in our
original subspace with this or with
anything in its orthogonal complement
you're going to get 0 so this term right
here is going to be 0 and you're just
going to get this term which is the same
thing as the length of our vector W
squared now that has to equal 0 remember
we just wrote X W XW X is a member of
the orthogonal complement of the
orthogonal complement so u dot that with
anything in the orthogonal complement
that's got to be equal 0 but if we write
it the other way if we write it as the
sum of V plus W and distribute this W we
say that's the same thing as the
magnitude of W squared so the magnitude
of W squared has got to be equal to 0
the magnitude of W squared or the length
of W squared has got to be equal to 0
which tells us that W is the 0 vector
that's the only vector in RN then when
you take its length and especially when
you square it you get 0 but you could
just take its length so what does that
mean that means that our original vector
X is equal to V plus W but W is just
equal to 0 so that implies that implies
that our original vector X that our
original vector X is equal to
is equal to V is equal to V and V is a
member of our subspace V right so that
tells us that X X is a member of our
subspace B so what we just show that if
it's something is a member of the of the
orthogonal complement of the orthogonal
complement then that same vector has to
be a member of the original subspace so
there is no such thing as something
being in the orthogonal complement of
the orthogonal complement and not being
a member of our original subspace all of
this all of this has to be has to be
inside of this right there so this there
is no outside blue space like that all
of that is our original subspace if you
want to view it that way now I just at
the beginning of this video said hey
anything in our subspace is going to be
a member of our orthogonal complement
that you can kind of reason that in your
head but let's use the same argument to
just be a little bit more rigorous about
it just be a little bit more rigorous
about it so let's say let's say right
now we say look if anything is in the
orthogonal complement of the orthogonal
complement then it's going to be in the
original subspace let's go the other way
let's say that something is in the
original subspace is in the original
subspace just like that if anything let
me draw another graph right here because
this might be useful
let me draw RN again let me draw all of
RN like that now we start we have the
orthogonal complement let me just draw
that first so V perp and then you have
your thought you have the complement you
have the orthogonal complement of the
orthogonal complement which could be
this set right here right this is V perp
perp I haven't even drawn the subspace V
all I've shown is I have some subspace
here which I happen to call V perp and
then I have the orthogonal complement of
that subspace so this means that
anything in RN can be represented as a
sum of a vector that's here an S and a
vector that's here so if I say if I say
that dub
you let me do it in purple if I say that
the vector W or let me write it this way
the vector V the vector V can be
represented as the sum of the vector W
and the vector and the vector X where
where W is a member of the orthogonal
complement of V or V perp and X is a
member of its orthogonal complement
notice all I'm saying I could have
called this set s and then this would
have been s and it's orthogonal
complement and we learned that anything
in RN can be represented in the sum of
something in a subspace and the
subspaces orthogonal complement so it
doesn't matter that V is somehow related
to this it can be represented as a sum
of a vector here plus a vector there
fair enough now what happens what
happens if I dot V if I dot V with W I'm
doing the exact same argument that I did
before well V anything if you take
anything that's a member of our original
subspace and you dot it with anything in
its orthogonal complement that's going
to give us zero
what what is what else is that going to
be equal to well if we take if we write
V in this way
V dot W is the same thing as this thing
dot W so W plus X dot W and this is
going to be equal to wwww plus X dot W
and then what's X dot W X is in the
orthogonal complement of the orthogonal
complement and W is in the orthogonal
complement so if you take their dot
product you're going to get 0 they're
orthogonal to each other
so this is just equal to W W or the
length of W squared and since that has
to equal 0 right we just have a bunch of
equals here that tells us that once
again the vector W has to be equal to 0
and that V so that tells us V is equal
to W plus X but if W is equal to 0 then
V is going to be equal to
so we've just shown that if if V is a
member of the subspace V then V is a
member of the orthogonal complement of
the orthogonal complement right V is
equal to X which is a member of the
orthogonal complement of the orthogonal
complement so we've proven it boat we've
proved proved both ways if you look at
the original statement we learned we
wrote here that if you're a member of
the orthogonal complement of the
orthogonal complement your original
member of the original subspace so we
proved this and earlier in the video we
proved that if X is a member of the
orthogonal complement of the orthogonal
complement then X is a member of our
subspace so these two things are
equivalent anything that's in the
subspace is a member of V perp perp ad
and V perp perp is a member of our
subspace so our subspace and V perp perp
are the same set and of course it
overlaps this equals this and of course
it overlaps with V perp it's orthogonal
complement only at the zero vector right
there